a developer on the division has revealed
that console players will be given even
more freedom to tweak the game's
graphical settings they he'll be stopped
to develop a told YouTube channel team
epiphany you can disable certain
lighting aspects to improve frame rates
in the console versions I don't know of
another game that does that so if you
want to choose frame rate over visuals
you can if you want for those of you
intending to play on PC anyway it's all
good news on that front - the developer
explained that they have always
considered the PC to be a separate
platform while creating the game adding
it's been good having a dedicated PC
build for this game I'm really happy
that we're pushing the PC built as much
as we are there's a lot more customized
options than the console players will be
able to tweak settings including
chromatic aberration image sharpening
and anti-aliasing let me know if you'd
like to see more games offer up these
graphical options on console and stay
tuned to game spot for all the latest
division needs